[Música]
las sirenas antiaéreas volvieron a sonar
en kiev a primera hora de la mañana de
este jueves horas más tarde el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin se reunía
en kazajistán con su homólogo Turco Rey
perdogan para debatir sobre cuestiones
energéticas y estrechar lazos con la
escalada bélica como telón de fondo en
el terreno las autoridades ucranianas
denunciaron un ataque con drones
kamikaze de fabricación iraní en la
región capitalina nikolaive una urbe al
sur del país fue blanco de nuevos
bombardeos más de 100 misiles rusos han
impactado en Ucrania desde el lunes
según el gobierno de bolodimir zelenski
que aprovechó su participación en el
consejo de Europa para pedir más
sistemas de defensa aérea
[Música]
queremos tener la capacidad de cerrar el
cielo nuestras capacidades No son
suficientes Alemania abrió el camino a
esta posibilidad proporcionándonos el
primer sistema iristete Estados Unidos
confirmó su apoyo con escudos
antimisiles nasams Nos gustaría que este
apoyo fuera mucho mayor por su parte
desde Moscú denunciaron ataques
ucranianos en un edificio Residencial en
la ciudad de belgorot próxima harky pero
del lado ruso de la frontera
un artefacto desconocido cayó después de
que se activaran las defensas aéreas los
años pueden verse aquí en el lugar en el
último piso
en la región de gerson una de las cuatro
provincias hanneccionadas
unilateralmente por Rusia el gobernador
local pidió al kremlin evacuar a la
población civil por las arremetidas de
las tropas ucranianas
los objetivos que alcanzan los misiles
son hoteles casas residenciales mercados
donde hay muchos civiles
mientras la guerra avanza los miembros
de la otan reunidos en Bruselas
reafirmaron su apoyo aquí es por tiempo
indefinido